AND UNSEEN," WHERE WE EXPLORE
AND EXPOSE THE CULTURAL STORIES
OF THE DAY.
WHY ARE ONLY CERTAIN FIRST
LADIES ALLOWED ON THE COVER OF
"VOGUE"?
SOCIAL MEDIA SELECTIVELY BANNING
SPEECH, AGAIN.
THE MEDIA BLACKOUT ADDITION OF
"SEEN AND UNSEEN," RAYMOND
ARROYO, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND
SELLING OFF AUTHOR OF THE WILL
WHILE THEIR SERIES.
WHY DO WE ONLY SEEM TO SEE ONE
PARTY REPRESENTED ON THE
MAGAZINE RACK?
TALKING ABOUT FIRST LADIES,
MICHELLE OBAMA ON PRETTY MUCH
EVERY MAGAZINE.
>> "VOGUE" EDITOR ANNA WINTOUR
>> "VOGUE" EDITOR ANNA WINTOU,
SAT DOWN WITH YOUR FAVORITE
JOURNALIST, CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR,
AND SHE EXPLAINED WHY CERTAIN
POLITICAL FIGURES AND FIRST
LADIES GET COVERS, AND OTHERS
DON'T.
>> I MEAN, YOU OVERTLY
POLITICAL, WHAT EXACTLY ARE YOU
TRYING TO SAY BY PROFILING
MICHELLE OBAMA OR KAMALA
HARRIS, OR EVEN STORMY DANIELS?
>> I BELIEVE, I THINK THOSE OF
US THAT LEFT AT CONDE NAST
BELIEVE YOU HAVE TO STAND UP FOR
WHAT YOU BELIEVE IN.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN PLEASE
EVERYBODY ALL THE TIME.
>> PLEASE EVERYBODY ALL THE
TIME.
WITH NO CONCERN ABOUT ALIENATING
VIEWERS OR READERS, WINTOUR WENT
ON.
>> IT IS NOTICEABLE THERE ARE
MORE DEMOCRATIC WOMEN, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN YOUR
MAGAZINE.
I WONDER IF THERE'S A REASON FOR
THAT?
>> IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO HAVE
A POINT OF VIEW.
WE PROFILE WOMEN IN THE MAGAZINE
THAT WE BELIEVE UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY ARE TAKING ON ISSUES, WE
SUPPORT THEM, AND THE FACT THAT
WE FEEL THEY ARE LEADERS.
>> THERE IS ONE WOMAN WHO WILL
NEVER APPEAR ON THE COVER OF ANY
ONE OF THESE MAGAZINES.
DO YOU KNOW WHO THAT WOMAN MIGHT
BE, LAURA?
>> Laura: LET'S SEE IT.
>> THE CONTROL ROOM HAS LOST
THAT WOMAN.
WRONG WOMAN, LAURA.
MAYBE THEY WILL FIGURE OUT BY
THE TIME I RETURN THESE CLASSES.
THERE IT IS.
THAT IS THE WOMAN.
BEFORE WE LEAVE, MENTIONED
MICHELLE OBAMA.
SHE HAS BEEN ON THREE OF THESE
"VOGUE" COVERS.
FOR THIS REASON, LAURA.
>> ON A VERY SELFISH NOTE, THE
EDITOR IN CHIEF OF "VOGUE," SHE
DID WONDERS FOR FASHION.
>> YOU SEE, SHE IS SO DIFFERENT
FROM THAT DOUBTING MILANI, SHE
SHE DOESN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
PASSION.
>> Laura: FIRST OF ALL, THE
FACT THAT ANNA WINTOUR MUST
CONTINUE TO WEAR THE GLASSES --
>> SHE HAS STATED IT SO PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW WHAT SHE IS THINKING.
>> Laura: SHE'S GOING TO PUT
ALL OF HER LIBERAL TRIPE I WOULD
PEERED WHAT ARE YOU WEARING
TONIGHT, BY THE WAY?
>> BIG NEWS.
>> Laura: SORRY TO INTERRUPT,
WE'VE GOT TO GET THROUGH IT.
THERE IS TONIGHT A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
CUMBERSOME AND ERIC SWALWELL
MADE A HUGE ANNOUNCEMENT ON "THE
COLBERT SHOW" TWO NIGHTS AGO.
IT WAS ONE OF THOSE MOMENTS IN
HISTORY.
>> I SEE A COUNTRY IN QUICKSAND,
UNABLE TO SOLVE PROBLEMS AND
THREATS FROM ABROAD, UNABLE TO
MAKE LIFE BETTER FOR PEOPLE.
I'M READY TO SOLVE THESE
PROBLEMS.
I'M RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> LAURA, LET'S GO ON.
THERE WAS A BIG BAND THIS WEEK
OF SOCIAL MEDIA VIDEO WITH TRUMP
SQUARING OFF WITH HIS
IDEOLOGICAL OPPONENTS.
THE MUSIC FROM "THE DARK KNIGHT"
WAS IN THE VIDEO.
90,000 LIKES, 2 MILLION PEOPLE
SAW IT.
IT WAS TAKEN DOWN FROM TWITTER
LAST NIGHT CITING COPYRIGHT
VIOLATION.
I CALL IT THE BATMAN BECAUSE
WARNER BROS. CLAIMS THE CLIP WAS
NOT AUTHORIZED FOR USE.
>> Laura: IS NOT A CAMPAIGN --
>> YOU'RE GETTING AHEAD OF ME.
YOU CANNOT USE MUSIC IN A
CAMPAIGN VIDEO AND THEY ARE
THREATENING LEGAL ACTION AGAINST
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Laura: I SAY BRING IT.
YOU THINK IF THEY GOT OBAMA FOR
THIS?
>> REMEMBER, THIS IS A PERSON IN
THE BLOGOSPHERE WHO POSTED A
VIDEO, NOT A CAMPAIGN EMPLOYEE.
OF THE FACT HE TWEETED IT, DOES
NOT MEAN ALL 90,000 RE-TWEETERS
ARE PILING COPYRIGHT?
I THINK NOT.
>> Laura: CAN I BORROW THESE
CLASSES?
>> YOU MAY NOT.
>> Laura: I DON'T WANT PEOPLE
TO KNOW WHAT THEY ARE THINKING.
WHY THE ACCENT?
FINALLY, DID YOU SEE WHERE THE
NATIONAL SCIENCE FOUNDATION
UNVEILED?
THERE HE DISAPPEARED AN ACTUAL
PHOTOGRAPH OF A BLACK HOLE.
>> PRETTY AMAZING, ACTUALLY.
>> Laura: THEY USED SEVERAL
TELESCOPES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WHEN YOU SAW
THIS?
>> WHEN I FIRST SAW IT, THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN I TAKE MY
GLASSES OFF AT THE DENTIST
OFFICE.
YOU LOOK UP AT THE LIGHT, THAT
IS HOW IT LOOKS.
WHAT DID YOU THINK WHEN YOU SAW
IT?
>> Laura: IT LOOKS LIKE THE
SOLAR ECLIPSE OR THE LUNAR --
BUT IT SCARES ME JUST TO LOOK AT
IT.
>> I KNOW THERE ARE BLACK HOLES
COME I WANT TO GO BACK TO A TIME
WHEN ANNA WINTOUR DIDN'T
POLITICALLY DECIDE WHO WAS ON
THE COVER OF "VOGUE."
THAT WOULD BE A NICE TIME.
>> Laura: YOU CAN GET SUCKED
IN AND GO BACK IN TIME.